hello guys I'm Greg with the lovely
Ashley and haha that's her name
Ashley Edna is an old friend of mine who
I met when I was like what 15 something
like that at a math tutoring yeah we
were homeschooled after we recently
reconnected she has a YouTube channel
how to's with Morgan and Ashley yes the
two hot girls teaching you how how did
you think how did you fun yeah Morgan
never met her she thought nothing funny
I've had that she's a nice person in
real life he's pretty as well just like
Ashley and you can follow them on
Instagram and Facebook how to blondes
make a right link in the description box
to get off the pole Ashley's personal
Instagram
Ashley ender on there all the time
constantly snooping around - factious
this is your first video with me on the
real rejects I thought we'd start simple
alright I'm nervous
actually like the laughs again
so Ashley we're going to do this
challenge video here it's a try not to
laugh or grin okay are you ready yeah
you can't even smile oh my god okay
funny kid fails compilation compilation
2016
so no laughing okay no smiling can I
cover my mouth there is no no no legal
gonna charge you all right you ready for
this
no but go just do your best and if you
[ __ ] up just start again and do whoever
does it first is a loser no no one's
winning or losing because watch the
whole thing I got you laughs just
restart okay go back to 9 how many yeses
I get to give this cute okay I'm back
kind of cool I yeah love you yeah ready
go
oh that happened to me before like you
lost that one I'll reminding you all the
other day oh come on kid Oh be careful
babe
hey buddy look around if our thoughts
are the laughing baby already threw the
ball so close
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like we're pretty tired right now
are you look over here whoa where's
Jaden at Dana what are you doing kid
what are you doing they're dead there is
a depth perception oh really good good
job
what up let me see yeah he's trying to
be a favorite person
mommy is disappointed it's this town all
right there by good person walk it off
these crying on you do mm-hmm
a running start very well a lot of
preparation were nothing oh oh why do
they think that that would work
hey laughing my food washing machine no
that's just Washington yeah the world
may have power but God's given me a
power even stronger in the world
oh poor isn't hard your station athletes
easy
yeah human body in there don't do it
don't do it no it's a good idea
no and there's no I can't
yeah we're talk what the hell yeah don't
even think of no quick way to get down
open your eyes open your eyes oh you go
all having to pull but you will pull
yourself oh oh so let me give it now
wasn't as hard as I thought it would be
I think pretty good I like yeah you did
really good you don't find anything
funny that's amazing
I am laughed a lot it was a lot of odds
of coz there baby yeah adorable name
kids are stupid kids dumb silly they do
so many idiotic thing it's what the pull
of thing my ex-girlfriend was once we
were like into the p90x for like two
days
oh yeah and they have to do the pull-up
bars and she like fell but then she
could crash into a wall Oh totally
damage your tailbone oh my god and I
laugh and continue my workout Lisbon
wait I'm in about a half hour later like
oh you're really in pain I bet there's a
funny tale nice guy you want yours one
day I do I do want I would like your
present areum well now we're young now
we all know everybody but yes I want to
Ashley's pregnant with my children if he
doesn't know it's like do you know how
my little injection time you get
girlfriend how does matter ya know this
it sounds like a different thing role of
it yeah now she's not pregnant
but we're working on it okay there's
something funny about kids hurting
themselves
I know but it's sad I don't know the
kids was like trying to jump into the
pool and they can't do firmly funny and
I don't know why that little ball be
heels like a little old man baby
yeah I like the subtle kids that were
the ones who were like learning how
human behavior work hmm
like when the mom could say no to that
one kid but the one I really got me was
was the kid the soccer ball hits one kid
in the face and then it kicks it again
and hits another kid in the face yes I
was good yeah
I think there should be a Hunger Games
but would like little kids at a
playground to play how creepy would
happen after a grumpy yeah no snacks no
naps and the kid shaving his head I've
done that as a child yeah actually I was
a kid with this whole ordeal where I
like shave the side like just the side
here and my mom was like what'd you do
to your hair and I got so scared that I
said it fell out she's like no you
shaved it why'd you shave it like no it
fell out and I stuck with this lie I
stuck with this lie that they took me to
the doctor all because I was lying
oh my god there's a very elaborate woman
the doctor was like yes this happens to
kids sometimes but I think it's all
right you know sometimes kid tears just
fall out even the doctor believes even
the doctor believe me and that's where
Greg became a pathological liar and
realize I can lie about anything after
that this is another holiday giving me a
discount resolve oh this is a YouTube
channel is it for my own personal
holiday okay this kind of makes you want
to have kids just a little bit just so
you can stream your laughs yeah I love
the parents who laugh at their kids when
they get injured and got help in love it
yeah like fall on their face on concrete
ah [ __ ] idiot because I got this on
camera so I can show my friends much of
an idiot you are
[Music]
man we can do the kids right good good
all right well that's it for this video
right now subscribe to the real reject
if you wish to check out Ashley and
Morgan on houses with Ashley now Morgan
Morgan and Ashley I argue that actually
should have gotten top billing because
probability is the most important thing
to anything so usually the guy she was
actually Star Trek beyond yeah
I have a photo I'm Q in the photo oh god
oh yeah yeah yeah she wouldn't Star Trek
beyond she's done a lot of other things
over the years and it's like go through
her IMD being you'll be like I have seen
that movie I have seen that I have seen
that I am not even heard of this hasn't
seen that I was probably nothing and she
erotic Lee dances when she's like 10
years old or something in Dickie Roberts
right oh yes I do and Dickie Roberts
Heather had a bow and bowline
that's your character yeah oh I don't
really had a character Nick is an erotic
child in that movie no now you guys
recognize her David Spade's crazy
dancing remember which would you would
that would be awesome get a lot more
views no that's not the way yeah that's
what you do you tease